un peu de musique savez-vous que la
batterie est le troisième instrument le
plus pratiqué en France des percussions
mise à l'honneur à vous dans le Sud
Touraine car ce samedi aura lieu la
deuxième édition du vous stock festival
organisé par Jean-Marie jouvant
professeur de batterie à vous un
événement gratuit tout l'après-midi pour
écouter ces élèves jouer en solo ou en
groupe le défi se synchroniser les
Turquie a assisté à une répétition
[Musique]
une performance presque chorégraphique
mais surtout musical aujourd'hui ils
sont 10 samedi ils seront 40 tous
derrière leur batterie leur but se
coordonner pour jouer tous en même temps
le même morceau c'est un peu compliqué
mais ça va pour l'instant qu'on pourrait
à 40 batteries là en fait il y a le son
de du groupe qui prend un peu le dessus
sur la musique il faut pas se faire
déstabiliser par la personne qui est à
côté ou derrière et ce qui est difficile
c'est de rester concentré sur le tempo
et de pas se laisser déstabiliser
alors que pour certains tout est déjà
réglé comme du papier à musique c'est
compliqué d'être en rythme quoi non j'en
ai déjà fait l'année dernière puis
j'avais déjà fait d'autres concerts à
d'autres endroits mais ça fait beaucoup
de fois que je suis en fait des concerts
et aussi Jean-Marie c'est un super prof
ce super prof comme dit Ryan c'est
également le créateur du Woodstock
festival Jean-Marie prépare cette année
la seconde édition toujours dans la
petite commune de vous du Sud Touraine
toute l'après-midi ils seront une
quarantaine d'élèves à se produire en
concert à tour de rôle entrecoupé de
Battles de batterie
on peut appeler ça les performance
quelque part c'est vrai que ça demande
une rigueur individuelle sur chaque
élève et puis une cohésion de groupe en
général ils répètent tous
individuellement et puis après on fait
un patch un petit puzzle en réunit tout
ceux qui sont disponibles et puis on
essaye de de coller un peu une mise en
place générale quoi
le Woodstock festival c'est donc samedi
2 septembre l'entrée est gratuite de 14
heures à 18h30 puis comptez 5 euros pour
assister aux deux concerts de groupe
locaux prévus dans la soirée